ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANT AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
AGUIAR-CURRY.
ARAMBULA.
BAUER-KAHAN BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BURNER **** BATH [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
CALDERON CARILLO.
CERVANTES CHAU. TEN DAVID CHIU.
CHOI.
KANSEN CHU.
COOLEY [inaudible]
COOPER [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM DALLY [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
DEEP [inaudible] EIGHT MEN FLORA
[inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
FRAZIER [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GABRIEL.
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ IS GRAY
[inaudible]
GRAYSON HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
CHOLERA KAMLAGER-DOVE
[inaudible]
KILEY LACKEY LEVINE LOW MOAN
LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY.
MEDINA.
MELENDEZ MULLIN.
MURATSUCHI.
NAZARIAN.
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL.
PATTERSON PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK.
QUIRK SILVA.
RAMOS RAY IS.
THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ.
RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS SANTIAGO SMITH STONE
[inaudible]
TING VOEPEL [inaudible]
WALDRON WEBER WICKS.
WOOD MISTER SPEAKER
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT WE
ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND IN
THE GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND FOR
THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN
REVEREND BOB OSHITA REVEREND
OSHA.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
MY PRIMARY MENTOR DR MAKSIM YOU
KEY.
WOULD DESCRIBE LIFE AS A
CONSTANT STATE OF DISEASE.
HE WOULD SAY.
THE WORLD IS CONSTANTLY CHANGING
SO WE ARE CONSTANTLY ADJUSTING
AND NEVER TO THE EIGHTIES.
FROM FLAPPING UP OUR PILLOWS
BEFORE WE SLEEP AT NIGHT
DEFINING THE RIGHT WATER
TEMPERATURE WHEN WE SHOWER IN
THE MORNING.
WE ARE ALWAYS SUGGESTING IN WAYS
GREAT AND SMALL.
NOWADAYS WE FLIP A SWITCH AND
LIGHT UP THE NIGHT.
WE TURN THE DIAL TO COOL THE
SUMMERS ARE WARM THE WINTERS.
ALTHOUGH WE MAY LIVE MUCH MORE
COMFORTABLY NOW.
WE ALSO LIVE IN AN ACCELERATED
PACE WITH EVEN MORE THIS FEES.
WE MAY EASILY BECOME IMPATIENT
TRYING TO JUGGLE THE MANY EVENTS
AND ACTIVITIES AND ARE WELL
SCHEDULE DAYS.
IMPATIENCE LEADS TO ANGER.
AND ANGER IS RARELY HELPFUL.
IN LIVING OUR BUSY LIVES
PATIENCE IS TOO EASILY LOST.
THE DALAI LAMA HAS SAID.
THE PRACTICE OF PATIENTS GUARD
SETH AGAINST LOSING OUR PRESENCE
OF MIND.
IT ENABLES US TO REMAIN
UNDISTURBED.
IT GIVES US A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
INNER PEACE SO THAT WE CAN
CHOOSE TO RESPOND TO SITUATIONS.
IN AN APPROPRIATE AND
COMPASSIONATE MANNER.
THE WORLD IS CONSTANTLY CHANGING.
AND WE ARE CONSTANTLY ADJUSTING
IN WAYS GREAT AND SMALL. TO HELP
MAINTAIN OUR MENTAL AND
EMOTIONAL WELL BEING.
LET US TRY EVEN MORE TO NURTURE
PATIENCE.
NOW MORE AMENABLE WITH KINDNESS
AND GRATITUDE BEYOND.
THANK YOU REVEREND ASHA WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE.
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAMOS SAYS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE.
THERE IS ONE HUNDRED AND OVER
HEART.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
OF THE UNITED STATES
[inaudible]
OUR INDIVISIBLE [inaudible]
YEAH.
YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO WEDNESDAY MARCH
THIRTEENTH TWENTY NINETEEN
RECENTLY MET AT SEVEN AM ON WILL
STEVEN CHOI ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SIXTY EIGHTH DISTRICT PRESIDING
CHEAPER KEY DIZER BONTA MOVES
AND MISTER FLORES SECONDS AT THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE TO
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS.
TODAY'S ABSENCES FOR LEGISLATIVE
BUSINESS ARE ASSEMBLYMEMBERS COM
LONGER DATA DOLLY IN FONG.
AT ABSENCE FOR ILLNESS MISTER
CALDERON AN ABSENCE FOR DEATH IN
THE FAMILY MISTER FREDDIE
RODRIGUEZ.
MR BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR MOTIONS.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND.
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE AND ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
BONTA WICKS JONES SAWYER.
CHEN AND GRAY. TO SPEAK ON EN
ADJOURNMENT MEMORY TODAY WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE. FIFTY SIX
TO ALLOW THE ASSEMBLY LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE. TO NOTICE
AB SIX FORTY EIGHT IS ERIN FOR
HEARING ON WEDNESDAY APRIL THIRD
PENDING REFERRAL FROM THE
ASSEMBLY HEALTH COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY
SIX I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO RE REFER THE FOLLOWING BILLS
TO COMMITTEE.
AB ONE FORTY ONE COOPER FROM THE
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE. TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE A BEFORE NINETY FIVE
MURATSUCHI FROM THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE TO THE ENVIRONMENTAL
SAFETY AND TOXIC MATERIALS
COMMITTEE AND THEN BACK TO THE
HEALTH COMMITTEE.
AB EIGHT FORTY SEVEN GRAYSON
FROM THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE TO THE RULES COMMITTEE
AND AB -- SEVENTEEN THIRTY SEVEN
POOR NOLTE FROM THE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER
.
MEMBERS WE HAVE GUESTS WITH US
IN THE ASSEMBLY TODAY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MELENDEZ YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GUEST
INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
I WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME AND
INTRODUCE TODAY STUDENTS AND
TEACHERS FROM MY DISTRICT HERE
IN SACRAMENTO THIS WEEKEND FOR
THE HEALTH OCCUPATIONS STUDENTS
OF AMERICA SPRING CONFERENCE.
IN THE GALLERY IS RACHEL CARROLL
WHO'S A WATER POLO COACH AND
TEACHER AT ELSINORE HIGH SCHOOL
CAMMIE WHALES WHO THE PTSA
PRESIDENT FOR THE LAKE ELSINORE
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE YOUR
SPECTRUM IS MELENDEZ.
THANK YOU AND OF COURSE ALL OF
OUR SPORTS MEDICINE STUDENTS OF
ELSINORE HIGH SCHOOL WELCOME
STUDENTS LADIES GERMAN PLEASE
GIVE THEM A ROUND OF APPLAUSE.
MOVING TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY
FILE.
ASSEMBLY SECOND READING FILE
ITEMS ONE THROUGH TWENTY SIX THE
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 558-622-82870
THIRTY FIVE SEVEN EIGHTEEN WITH
THE MOMENT SIX EIGHTY SIX AT THE
MOMENT TEN SIXTY THREE EIGHT
NINETY NINE SEVEN EIGHTY ONE
WITH THE MOMENT SEVEN THIRTEEN
WITH A MOMENT FIVE SIXTY FIVE
WITH THE MOMENT SEVEN OH FOUR
WITH AMENDMENTS TO SEVENTY FOUR
WITH THE MEMONS. TO SEVENTEEN
WITH THE MOMENT ELEVEN EIGHTY
WITH THE MEMONS FIFTEEN HUNDRED
AT THE MOMENT. NINE OH THREE
WITH THE MEMONS NINE FORTY SIX
TEN THIRTEEN TO ABOUT THREE SIX
EIGHTY WITH THE MEMONS THREE
THIRTY EIGHT WITH THE MEMONS TEN
NINETY TWO WITH THE MENACE NINE
TWENTY FIVE AT THE MOMENT SIX
FORTY EIGHT WITH THE MOMENT AND
THREE EIGHTY THREE WITH MOMENTS.
OF BILLS OF DEEP BEEN DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED
.
MOVING TO ASSEMBLY THIRD READING
FILE ITEMS TWENTY SEVEN AND
TWENTY EIGHT WILL BE PASSED THE
RETAINS.
FILE ITEM THIRTY AB ONE THIRTY
SEVEN THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE THIRTY SEVEN
BY THE ONLY MEMBER COOPER AND
ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC SAFETY
OFFICERS.
MR COULD REMAIN OPEN.
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS AB ONE
THIRTY SEVEN SIMPLY SEEKS TO
CLARIFY EXISTING LAW IS APPLIED
TO PUBLIC UNION EMPLOYEE RIGHTS.
AB ONE THIRTY SEVEN CLARIFY THE
DEFINITION OF THE NATURE OF THE
INVESTIGATION.
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEEDINGS BY
STATING WHAT INFORMATION IS
NEEDED TO SUFFICIENTLY NOTICE
THE EMPLOYEE.
AB ONE THIRTY SEVEN WILL BRICK
THE LADIES IN THE ADMINISTRATIVE.
INVESTIGATIVE PROCESS AND REMOTE
QUICKER RESOLUTION TO COMPLAINTS.
AB ONE THREE SEVEN IS.
CRITICAL IN MEETING THE EMPLOYER
EMPLOYEE RELATIONSHIPS AND
WILSHIRE A HARMONIOUS FAIR A
PRODUCTIVE WORKPLACE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER COOPER.
SEEING AND HEARING NO DISCUSSION
ON THIS ITEM YOU MAY CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
AB.
ONE THIRTY SEVEN ALL MEMBERS WHO
DESIRED -- PLEASE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESERT ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE.
THAT VOTE ON AB ONE THIRTY SEVEN
IS FORTY SIX I'D THREE NAY THE
ITEM PASSES.
FILE ITEM THIRTY ONE WILL BE
PASSED TO RETAIN MOVING TO FILE
ITEM THIRTY TWO A. B. THREE
FIFTY SIX MR SANTIAGO YOU MAY
OPEN.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER SANTIAGO
THE CLERK WILL READ FIRST THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY BILL THREE FIFTY
SIX BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO
AND ACTUALLY THE BEST VALUE
PROCUREMENT.
NOW MR SANTIAGO THANK YOU THANK
YOU MAN SPEAKER MEMBERS AB THREE
FIFTY SIX WERE AUTHORIZED A
PILOT PROGRAM FOR THE LOS
ANGELES COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT USE BEST VALUE
PROCUREMENT METHODS. FOR
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS EXCEEDING
ONE MILLION DOLLARS -- THIS FALL
OF LEGISLATION THAT DOES SIMILAR --
SIMILAR ACTS FOR THE UC SYSTEM
AND LA U. S. D. ALSO ON WE JUST
BY CLASS RIVAL.
SEEING AND HEARING NO DISCUSSION
ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE ON AB.
THREE FIFTY SIX ALL MEMBERS WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE PLEASE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
THAT [inaudible]
YEAH.
I'M MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE.
TALLY THE VOTE.
I FORTY NINE FIVE KNOWS
[inaudible]
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM.
FILE ITEM THIRTY THREE A. B.
FIVE NINETY FIVE THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE NINETY FIVE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MEDINA AND
ACTUALLY THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
MR MEDINA YOU MAY OPEN ON THIS
MEASURE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB FIVE NINETY FIVE
WOULD CREATE A PATH. TO ALLOW
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS TO ENTER
ALLIED HEALTH AND OTHER
APPRENTICESHIP.
AN INTERNSHIP TRAINING PROGRAMS
WITHOUT HAVING TO ENROLL IN THE
DOCK A PROGRAM.
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
OFFER A WIDE ARRAY OF PROGRAMS
THAT REQUIRE PARTICIPATION.
IN APPRENTICESHIP INTERNSHIP
PROGRAMS.
HOWEVER MANY OF THESE PROGRAMS
REQUIRE STUDENTS TO HAVE A VALID
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER.
WHICH IS IMPOSSIBLE.
WHICH IS AN IMPOSSIBLE OBSTACLE
FOR UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS WHO DO
NOT QUALIFY FOR DHAKA.
THE IRS ISSUES AN INDIVIDUAL TAX
IDENTIFICATION NUMBER. TO
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE REQUIRED TO
HAVE THE US TAXPAYER
IDENTIFICATION NUMBER.
BUT WHO DO NOT HAVE AN ARE NOT
ELIGIBLE TO OBTAIN A SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBER.
I. T. I. N. S. ARE NOT AN
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT TOOL AND
SHARING APPLICANTS PRIVATE
INFORMATION.
IS NOT NECESSARY FOR ENSURING
TAX COMPLIANCE.
AB FIVE NINETY FIVE WOULD ALLOW
USING THE INDIVIDUAL I TI AND IN
LIEU OF A SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER
FOR THOSE STUDENTS WHO DON'T
HAVE A SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER.
THE BILL HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON THIS MATTER.
AT THE CLERK WILL.
OPEN THE ROLE ON A. B..
FIVE NINETY FIVE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED AS OUR TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRED OF
A THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTE.
I FIFTY TWO NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES.
MOVING TO ITEM NUMBER THIRTY
FOUR A. B. TWO OH FIVE THE CLERK
WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO OH FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALY AND
ACTUALLY THE ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE YOUR
ATTENTION MR DAILY MR DAILY YOU
MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
THIS BILL UPDATES AND MODERNIZES
THE ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE CODE. TO
ALLOW CALIFORNIA'S CRAFT BREWERS
OF WHICH THERE ARE OVER NINE
HUNDRED NOW IN OUR STATE. TO
CONTINUE PRODUCING A DIVERSIFIED
SELECTION OF BEER PRODUCTS.
IT EXPANDS THE DEFINITION OF
BEER TO INCLUDE INGREDIENTS SUCH
AS HONEY FRUIT AND OTHER FOOD
PRODUCTS [inaudible]
THESE.
THESE INNOVATIVE BEER.
PRODUCTS HAVE PROVEN TO BE VERY
POPULAR WITH CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS.
AND I WILL RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON THIS MATTER THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRED OF
A MEMBERS THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
I'M MEMBERS VOTED AS ART OF A
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE.
I SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO THIS
MEASURE PASSES.
ITEMS NUMBER THIRTY FIVE THREE
THIRTY SEVEN WE PASSED THE
RETAINS MOVING TO EITHER FILE
ITEM NUMBER.
THIRTY EIGHT AB SEVEN SEVENTY
FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN SEVENTY FIVE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHILD AND
ACTUALLY THE HEALING ARTS.
MR CHOW YOU MAY OPEN ON THIS
MATTER THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS SO AB SEVEN
SEVEN FIVE WITH STREAMLINED THE
APPROVAL PROCESS FOR MASSAGE
THERAPY SCHOOLS.
BY THE CALIFORNIA MASSAGE
THERAPY COUNCIL OR C. A M. T. C..
IT WOULD ALSO REQUIRE THAT
STUDENTS BE NOTIFIED WHEN THEY
ARE ATTENDING A NON APPROVED
SCHOOL WHICH CAN JEOPARDIZE
THEIR ABILITY TO BECOME
CERTIFIED THERAPIST OR
PRACTITIONERS.
CURRENTLY THERE IS NO FIXED
TIMELINE FOR SCHOOL APPROVAL
THERE IS ONLY A ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTY DAY PROCESS FOR CA ON T.
C. TO APPROVE OR DENY AS SCHOOL
UPON RECEIPT OF A COMPLETED
APPLICATION.
HOWEVER IN REALITY IT OFTEN
TAKES MUCH LONGER TO RECEIVE A
FINAL DECISION.
IN FACT SOME APPLICATIONS HAVE
BEEN PENDING FOR TWO TO THREE
YEARS.
MEANWHILE STUDENTS WHO ATTENDED
THE SCHOOLS ARE UNABLE TO OBTAIN
CERTIFICATION IMPACTING THEIR
LIVELIHOOD.
AB SEVEN SEVEN FIVE WOULD
PROVIDE BETTER NOTICE TO
STUDENTS WHEN THEY ATTEND A
SCHOOL WHICH IS NOT APPROVED
WHILE ALSO REDUCING THE TIME
PERIOD FOR APPROVING A SCHOOL
AND PROVIDING MORE CERTAINTY. TO
THE STUDENTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON THIS MATTER THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESIRED ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
I'LL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY FIVE NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
BY LATE I'M THIRTY NINE WILL BE
PASSED ENTERTAINS.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM TWENTY NINE
EIGHTY TWO OH SIX THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO OH SIX BY
FAMILY MEMBER TO AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY A PUBLIC NUISANCE.
MR CHIU YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
THIS BILL WOULD HELP PROTECT
PROPERTY OWNERS FROM FRIVOLOUS
LAWSUITS IF THEY PARTICIPATE IN
THE LEAD PAINT ABATEMENT
PROGRAMS THAT WOULD PROTECT
FAMILIES AND KIDS FROM THE
IMPACT OF LEAD.
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT CAME OUT
OF A LANDMARK LEGAL DECISION
THAT FOUND LEAD PAINT COMPANIES
LIABLE FOR KNOWINGLY PROFITING.
FROM PRODUCTS WITH DOCUMENTED
HEALTH RISKS AND CREATING A
PUBLIC NUISANCE.
THESE COMPANIES ARE NOW REQUIRED
TO PAY HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS INTO A LEAD ABATEMENT
PROGRAM.
THEY HAVE SUGGESTED THAT THERE
TWO SENTENCES IN A ONE HUNDRED
FORTY THREE PAGE COURT CASE THAT
COULD LEAD TO LAWSUITS AGAINST
HOMEOWNERS WHO PARTICIPATE IN
THESE PROGRAMS.
WHILE THESE LAWSUITS WOULD BE
FRIVOLOUS THE THREAT OF A
LAWSUIT COULD ALSO DETER
PARTICIPATION SO THIS BILL WOULD
PROTECT PROPERTY OWNERS WHO
CHOOSE TO PARTICIPATE IN THESE
PROGRAMS.
THIS BILL IS SUPPORTED BY THE
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION OF THE
REALTORS CITIES AND COUNTIES
AROUND THE STATE. TEN IN
ORGANIZATIONS ENVIRONMENTAL AND
HEALTH ORGANIZATIONS I
APPRECIATE THE UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN COMMITTEE
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON THIS MATTER THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS GO TO DESIRE TO THE
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE.
I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO THIS MEASURE
PASSES.
MOVING TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
DOES ANY MEMBER WHICH REMOVE AN
ITEM FROM TODAY'S CONSENT
CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING ON THE CLERK
WILL READ THIS.
SECOND A CONSENT CALENDAR.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE SIXTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEYAND
OTHERS AND EXPLAIN TO GUIDE
SIGNAL AND SERVICE DOGS
[inaudible]
OKAY.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE IN
THE CALENDAR.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESIRED OF A
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE.
I SIXTY NINE NO ZERO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED THE CLERK
WILL READ THE REMAINING ITEMS ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE EIGHTY NINE I
SIXTY NINE NO ZERO S. ONLY ABLE
TO THIRTY NINE I SIXTY NINE NO
ZERO ONLY ABLE TO NINETY NINE I
SIXTY NINE NO ZERO ON THE BILL.
FIFTY SEVEN AYE SIXTY NINE KNOWS
HERE ONLY BILL FIVE NINETY SEVEN
I SIXTY NINE NO ZERO HOUSE
RESOLUTION TWENTY SIX I SIXTY
NINE NO ZERO IS ON THE
RESOLUTION THIRTY SEVEN AYE
SIXTY NINE NO ZERO AND SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION THREE I
SIXTY NINE NO.
ZERO MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS.
FIRST WE'D LIKE TO WISH A HAPPY
BIRTHDAY TO OUR COLLEAGUE MISS
WALDRON.
THIS SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS FRIDAY MARCH TWENTY
NINTH IS A HOLIDAY.
CESAR CHAVEZ DAY MONDAY APRIL.
FIRST WE WILL HAVE FLOOR SESSION
AT ONE PM.
IN THE ABSENCE OF AN OBJECTION
THE QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED AND WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORIES.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR
.
MEMBERS THE QUORUM CALL IS
LIFTED WE WILL MOVE TO OUR
PREVIOUSLY SCHEDULED ADJOURNMENT
AND MEMORIES
.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
SIR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
THE FLOOR.
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN OUR
TOURNAMENTS IN MEMORY.
MR GRAY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS.
I RISE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
TWENTY FIRST ASSEMBLY DISTRICT.
YOUR JOURNAL THE MEMORY ETHAN
MORSE.
HE THEN WAS TRAGICALLY GUNNED
DOWN IN OUR WATER ON MARCH
FIFTEENTH.
IF THERE WAS A STANDOUT WRESTLER
GOLD ALL HIGH SCHOOL.
EARNED ALL LEAGUE HONORS ALL
ACADEMIC HONORS WAS A STATE
QUALIFIER FOR CA OF STATE
WRESTLING FINALS.
YOUR INTERESTING SCHOLARSHIP TO
WASHY TO BAPTIST COLLEGE IN
ARKANSAS.
HE WAS CURRENTLY ATTENDING
MERCED COMMUNITY COLLEGE IN
MERCED.
ETHAN WAS A PRINCIPLED YOUNGMAN.
WHO STOOD UP FOR OTHERS?
EVEN IN THE FACE OF GREAT
ADVERSITY.
HE WAS KIND [inaudible]
COMPASSIONATE.
AND FIERCELY LOYAL TO HIS FAMILY
AND FRIENDS.
EVEN AS THE SIGN OF LONGTIME
MERCER COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY
LARRY MORSE AND HIS WIFE CINDY.
FATHER TO TWO YEAR OLD EVA.
WE WILL BE HE WILL BE REMEMBERED
FONDLY BY HIS BROTHERS DILLON
AND RYAN.
MORE MISSED BY ALL WHO KNEW HIM.
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME.
THIS MORNING ADJOURNING IN THE
MEMORY.
THE THE MORSE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS TODAY
I ALONG WITH MY COLLEAGUES FROM
OAKLAND.
AND LOS ANGELES RISE TO JOURNEY
MEMORY OF VICTOR MACKEL HANEY.
WHO WAS TRAGICALLY KILLED BY GUN
VIOLENCE ON MARCH TENTH?
OF THIS YEAR VICTOR MACRO HANEY
WAS JUST TWENTY ONE YEARS OLD.
HE WAS THE ONLY SON OF OAKLAND
CITY COUNCIL MEMBER AT LYNETTE
GIPSON MACRO HANEY.
AND HER HUSBAND.
CLARENCE MCKINNEY.
VICTOR WAS ALSO A TREASURED SON
OF THE EAST BAY'S ARTISTIC AND
ACTIVISTS COMMUNITIES.
HE WAS THE SON OF OAKLAND.
VICTOR WAS A MUSICAL PRODIGY.
HE RECEIVED HIS FIRST DRUM SET
AT THE AGE OF TWO HE BEGAN
STUDYING PERCUSSION.
AT A YOUNG AGE AND EARNED THE
HONOR OF REPRESENTING THE UNITED
STATES IN BEIJING.
AT THE INTERNATIONAL CULTURAL
FAIR.
AT THE AGE OF NINE HE CONTINUED
HIS TRAINING EVENTUALLY EARNING
HIS DIPLOMA FROM THE OAKLAND
SCHOOL FOR THE ARTS.
HE WENT ON TO CO FOUND A BAND
CALLED THE CHARM.
AND THROUGHOUT HIS YOUNG CAREER
HE PLAYED WITH AN OPEN FOR
CONTEMPORARY OAKLAND MUSICIANS
LIKE KEPT CHOICE.
JENNIFER JOHNS.
TONY TONY TONY AND BLACKALICIOUS
PERFORMING AROUND THE BAY AREA
AND INTERNATIONALLY.
NOT ONLY WAS VICTOR A TALENTED
AND GIFTED MUSICIAN HE DEEPLY
CARED ABOUT HIS OAKLAND
COMMUNITY.
HE GAVE COUNTLESS HOURS TO
SUPPORT COMMUNITY ACTIVITIES
INCLUDING WORKING WITH THIS
CHURCH TO END VIOLENCE.
AND HOMICIDES AFTER GRIEVING THE
DEATH OF A CLOSE FAMILY MEMBER.
HIS FAMILY AND FRIENDS KNEW HIM
AS A QUIET THOUGHTFUL AND CARING
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS LOVED AND WILL
BE MISSED.
BY MANY IN OAKLAND AND BEYOND.
HIS LEGACY OF BEAUTIFUL MUSIC IS
ONLY ONE ASPECT OF HOW PEOPLE
REMEMBER VICTOR.
HE WAS A MUSICIAN.
ACTIVIST AND MENTOR.
WHO DREW HIS INSPIRATION FROM
THE BEAT SOUL AND SOUND?
OF THE TOWN.
AND HE BELONG IN EVERY NOOK AND
CRANNY [inaudible]
OF OAKLAND.
AS THEY AND WE MOURN VICTOR'S
PASSING HIS FAMILY AND LOVED
ONES ARE ALSO EMPOWERED WITH A
RENEWED SENSE.
OF PURPOSE TO KEEP FIGHTING TO
AND THE DEVASTATING CONSEQUENCES
OF GUN VIOLENCE.
I ASK THAT THE ASSEMBLY JOIN ME.
AND MY COLLEAGUES TO JOIN IN THE
MEMORY OF VICTOR MCAVENNIE.
THANK YOU MISTER BONTA ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WICKS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
ON THIS THE GERMAN MEMORY.
THANK YOU SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
IS WITH A HEAVY HEART THAT I TO
RISE AND INJURED IN MEMORY OF
VICTOR MEDICAL HANEY.
A TWENTY ONE YEAR OLD LOCAL
NATIVE WHOSE LIFE WAS TRAGICALLY
CUT SHORT.
ON SUNDAY MARCH TENTH WHEN HE
WAS SHOT AND KILLED DURING AN
ATTEMPTED ROBBERY.
VICTOR WAS A TALENTED MUSICIAN
WHO ACCORDING TO HIS FAMILY.
WAS DRUMMING BEFORE HE COULD
WALK.
AT AGE ELEVEN VICTOR BEGAN
STUDYING AT THE OAKLAND PUBLIC
CONSERVATORIES MUSIC.
AND CONTINUE TO HONE HIS CRAFT
OF THE EAST BAY CENTER FOR THE
PERFORMING ARTS THE OAKLAND
SCHOOL FOR THE ARTS AND THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY EAST
BAY.
VICTOR TRANSFERRED TO USC'S
THORNS SCHOOL OF MUSIC IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN AND IS SAID TO HAVE.
HAD AN EYE TOWARDS FOLLOWING THE
GREAT JAZZ ARTISTS TRYING TO
THAT SCHOOL.
AND WANTED TO UTILIZE THE POWER
OF MUSIC AS A TOOL FOR SOCIAL
ACTIVISM.
VICTOR BELIEVE THAT MUSIC COULD
CHANGE THE WORLD.
HAVING LOST A CLOSE FAMILY
MEMBER TO GUN VIOLENCE.
VICTOR ADVOCATED FOR GUN CONTROL
AND ACTIVELY SUPPORT THE EFFORTS
OF HIS MOTHER.
OAKLAND'S COUNCILMAN LYNETTE
GIPSON MICHAEL HANEY. TO CREATE
THE DEPARTMENT OF VIOLENCE
PREVENTION IN OAKLAND.
AND COUNSEL MAC LANEY'S LAST
TEXT HER HER SON [inaudible]
SHE ASKED.
ARE YOU SAVE.
HE RESPONDED YES.
AND SHE REPLIED OKAY SWEET
DREAMS.
AN HOUR LATER HE WAS SHOT AND
KILLED.
A MOTHER TRAGICALLY LOSING HER
CHILD TO SENSELESS GUN VIOLENCE.
IS BECOMING A REGULAR STORY IN
AMERICA.
AND THIS COULD NOT BE OUR NEW
NORMAL.
SUCH LOSS IS NOT NORMAL.
NOBODY HERE TO HAVE TO
EXPERIENCE THIS.
VICTOR WAS A LOVING SON A GIFTED
MUSICIAN WHO WANTED TO USE HIS
TALENT TO CHANGE THE WORLD.
HE WILL BE GREATLY MISSED BY HIS
FAMILY HIS FRIENDS AND THE
COMMUNITIES OF OAKLAND AND U. S.
C..
LYNETTE AND CLARENCE.
WE HOLD YOU CLOSE IN OUR HEARTS
AND SURROUND YOU WITH LOVE.
I ASKED HIS HOUSE TO ADJOURN THE
MEMORY IF IT DRAMATICALLY.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER WAX
ASSEMBLYMEMBER JONES SAWYER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED ON THIS
INTERMINABLY.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY WITH MY COLLEAGUES FROM
OAKLAND WITH A HEAVY HEART TO
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF VICTOR
VICTOR MACRO HANEY.
IT IS SAD TO SEE ANYONE BE THE
VICTIM OF A SENSELESS CRIME.
BUT IS ALWAYS MORE HEARTBREAKING
WHEN THAT LOSS IS AT SUCH A
YOUNG AGE.
AS BOTH A MEMBER OF THE OF AB AT
THE BOTH THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REPRESENTING U. S. C. AND A
PROUD ALUMNUS OF U. S. C. HURTS
ME TO HAVE LOST.
A MEMBER OF THE TROJAN FAMILY.
THE MOST IMPORTANT [inaudible]
THE FATHER.
WHOSE HOME IS VERY CLOSE TO
WHERE VICTOR WAS KILLED.
AS THE FATHER OF A SEVENTEEN
YEAR OLD WHO EVERY DAY.
GOES TO A LOCAL MARKET TO GET A
SODA OR SOME CANDY OR POTATO
CHIPS.
I AM UNBELIEVABLY CONCERNED NOT
ONLY ABOUT.
THE NEIGHBORHOOD WHAT'S GOING ON
BUT OF MY OWN SON WHAT COULD
HAPPEN TO HIM JUST GOING TO THE
STORE. TO DO SOMETHING THAT WE
THINK IT'S JUST [inaudible]
JUST REGULAR -- I AGREE FOR THE
FAMILY -- AGREE FOR THE WHOLE.
MY HOPE CONSTITUENTS THE IN THAT
AREA BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN RAVAGED
BY THIS FOR QUITE SOME TIME.
ANGELOU SOMEONE LIKE VICTOR A
STUDENT AT THE PORT IN SCHOOL
MUSIC WHERE HE DISTINGUISHED
HIMSELF.
I DON'T THINK YOU UNDERSTAND HE
DISTINGUISHED HIMSELF AS AN
ACCOMPLISHED PERCUSSIONIST AND A
JAZZ STUDIES MAJOR.
HE WAS AN ACTIVE MEMBER OF IN
THE U. S. C. CENTER FOR BLACK
CULTURAL AND STUDENT AFFAIRS.
AND AS A TESTAMENT. TO THE
IMPACT VICTOR LEFT ON THE
STUDENT BODY.
MORE THAN SEVEN HUNDRED STUDENTS
GATHER THAT THE CAMPUS FOR
MEMORIAL SERVICE IN HIS HONOR
[inaudible]
ADDITIONALLY.
UNIVERSITY SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
HAS ANNOUNCED A CAUGHT
SCHOLARSHIP TO BE CREATED IN HIS
NAME.
THE ENTIRE TROJAN FAMILY MOURNS
THIS LOSS THANK YOU AND I HOPE
WE ALL KEEP FIXTURES FAMILY IN
OUR HEARTS.
I AFTER WE JOURNEY A MEMBER.
OF THE TO MAKE ALKALINE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES
SAWYER.
pRECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
TODAY A LIKE TO TURN IN THE
MEMORY.
OF MY ME GREEN RODRIGUEZ.
I ONLY WAS MOTHER YOUR BILL IN
THE COUNCIL MEMBER CARLOS
RODRIGUEZ AND PASSED AWAY ON
SUNDAY.
MARCH TENTH.
SHE WAS BORN IN BRONX IN NEW
YORK CITY AND WAS A MOTHER OF
THREE CHILDREN.
CARLOS BEING THE OLDEST. ONE
CALLED WAS TWO YEARS OLD MY
MOVED HER FAMILY TO LONG BEACH
CALIFORNIA TO SCORE A BETTER
LIFE FOR HER.
AND HER FAMILY.
THE FAMILY LATER MOVED TO RANCHO
CUCAMONGA AND EVENTUALLY LOCATED
UPLAND.
WHAT ASSN CARLOS ABOUT HIS
MOTHER?
CRAWFORD WAS STATED SHE WAS MY
HERO.
MY ROLE MODEL MY INSPIRATION.
NAOMI WITH MISSED BY MANY AND AS
A RETURN IN HER MEMORY.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER TEN
MEMBERS PLEASE BRING THE NAMES
TO THE DEATH TO BE PRINTED IN
THE JOURNAL.
ALL REQUESTS TO JOURNEY MEMORY
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED
IN THE JOURNAL.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED ENTERTAINED.
ON MOTION SHALL BE CONTINUED.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MR BONTA MOVES IN MR CHAN'S
SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL MONDAY APRIL
FIRST AT ONE PM